dr clarke ma meilleure amie et elle est
morte ou tuer la
radio date et écoutez moi j'ai fait de
quoi vous avez peur mais je suis plus
cette fille dépressive dix mois en duel
je suis vraiment désolé
vous aviez inscrit dans son répertoire
comme la personne à appeler en cas
d'urgence ou et basses oeuvres je veux
simplement l'avoir parce qu'elles n'ont
pas les conseils brice taton
[Musique]
parce que le docteur clarke mais c'est
le suivant janus on s'apprêtait
s'apprêtait à dîner vous voulez vous
joindre à nous je sais ce que vous êtes
en train de prouver je suis désolé une
famille c'était sociale et vous en avez
une superbe
je ne suis pas votre ennemi donc leur
clark jeunesse au métier de policier
c'est quoi ton problème avec ce fric
je pense que cette j'aime ce qui est
derrière ça
buzz non
[Musique]
pourquoi tu me regardent comme ça tu
fais comme si qui me croyais pas
ça les auteurs
james blake est un individu très
dangereux j'ai dit d'arrêter la voiture
parce qu'il est cliniquement fou je la
tue lui serait ce qu'à l'intérieur mais
qui portait la double auto
suit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je sais encore sénateur